Here is my first question for you guys, the 10 most heard things from scouts at summer
camp.
I don't know, I don't pay much attention to scouts at summer camp, but I don't know
stuff like. you know, where are my shoes and? and, um, ah, the spiders. um, what time
is dinner
On Friday after you? yeah, same time as all the other four days.
Tom, you were just at camp. what, what did you hear all week?
Can we go to the training post?
Well, what do you think?
Well, the first year, guys asking you know, can I go wherever? and I say: where's your
buddy?
You know beyond, you know, can I have a blue card?
Um, can I have a blue card?
That's about it.
So the second question is: uh, what do you tell your scouts 300 times while you're
at summer camp?
Go talk to the senior patrol later.
I don't know,
I don't know.
Oh, no,
They look at me and they go. you, you don't know. no, I don't know.
So where are we supposed to be?
I don't know.
Is there a campfire tonight?
Go check the schedule. found the board,
And when I say that I mean it. it's like you know, about five minutes
to seven, the other dolls will come around and go. we going to the campfire.
Oh, is there a campfire tonight?
Where are the boys?
I don't know.
Hey, this is spot. count is number 126..
Welcome back to the scout master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Hey, what did you hear at summer camp?
What did you tell the scouts at summer camp?
There was a little sampling there from the guys in the scout master
panel discussion.
We're going to hear more of that in a little while,
But first let's take a look in this week's mail bag. James Chaplin, who
is an assistant scout master for troop 1833, wrote in to say: another great
podcast.
I enjoyed it and ordered the book free range kids after reading your review
online.
Thanks.
Well, thank you, James.
Another message about last week's podcast from Frank Maynard, who said:
Lenore Scanesi views parenting with a fresh perspective and helps us break
out of that kind of overprotective shell we have.
Changing our children's activities too closely can take away from their
sense of accomplishment,
And that's exactly what we put back in scouting.
The key takeaway in Lorraine's book was summed up in the interview:
We're not raising children, we're raising adults.
Thanks for that, Frank.
Frank Maynard has a blog called Bob White's Blather.
Make sure you go over and check it out-
Always good stuff on there.
Over on Google plus we heard from Robert Schleich who said: normally your
podcasts are around 30 minutes and that's a perfect time for my
commute to work.
I found myself sitting in the car in the parking lot to finish podcast
number 125 with Lenore Scanesi.
I did not miss work, however.
I just ate breakfast in the car instead of at my desk.
Well, thanks, Robert.
Thanks for your kind words there.
Rick Stoner wrote in and said: yeah, that was a good show.
I agree with the thought that the 24-hour news entertainment shows
blast this stuff out to viewers as if it was happening in their
neighborhoods,
Not in the basic lack of understanding of statistics and
probability. and no wonder parents are worried.
Well, yeah, that's kind of the thing.
It's not parent's fault if they get worried about stuff kind of
irrationally because, like you said, Rick, it's just getting
blasted into our homes and we believe that all this danger is
right there in our neighborhood.
Well, this week is our monthly scout master panel discussion
where we're going to be talking about emergency preparedness
and disaster training for scouts, and there are some
excellent resources in the post that contains this podcast
and we'll mention them during the discussion.
So you want to make sure to check those out.
And you know, without further ado, we're going to move right
to that scout master panel discussion.
So let's get started, shall we?
It's time for another scout master panel discussion.
So we're back for another scout master panel discussion,
and joining me is Larry Geiger, down in Vera, Florida.
How you doing, Larry?
Good evening, Clark doing good.
And Tom Gillard in Tullahoma, Tennessee,
who's baking away in the summer heat.
How you doing, Tom?
We're doing fine, Clark, thanks.
Tom actually can put a Dutch oven out in his driveway
and cook dinner-
Almost
That's what he was telling me-
190 degrees on the asphalt.
And Walter Underwood out in California,
where it's disgustingly 80 degrees and very dry
and beautiful.
How you doing, Walter?
It was fine.
I was glad that it was pleasant today
because I was helping build a house
for habitat of humanity,
So it would have been difficult in your kind of weather.
Now, was that a scout thing? you did?
Yep, it was with work.
Oh, okay.
So the engineering team went out
and grabbed actual physical tools for change.
Oh gracious,
I hope you alerted the habitat people before you did that.
Oh, yes,
The English majors don't make mistakes
because they follow instructions.
Engineers have bright ideas,
And today we're going to talk about
one of the more tangible results of scouting:
emergency preparedness: anything from a scraped knee
to a real, honest to God disaster.
And, Walter, this was your idea for a topic.
And what's your involvement with emergency response?
Well, I'm a ham radio operator
and I'm involved in a local emergency communication group
And so that's my weekly kind of involvement,
is checking in on that,
And so I've had taken a couple of online courses
about the incident command and read up on some things.
Of course, I grew up in Louisiana,
So I've been through a couple of hurricanes
and out here I've been through a couple of earthquakes
and I don't know, maybe you shouldn't live close to me-
That's what everybody says in California-
because the weather's so nice
They don't want people there messing it up.
Another thing: we had a city thing called Quakeville
where people would camp in a city park
And it was an awareness thing about earthquake.
We had things and the Scouts were one of the volunteers
for this, but we didn't have a particular job
because they're not like Red Cross or somebody
who had something specific that they know how to do
and could fit into the system.
But it turned out they were very useful
because you need groups of these guys
who can be safe in the outdoors,
who can work together in small groups
and get stuff done on their own,
And so they helped lay out the campsites
and help people set up their tents and stuff,
and they would run messages
And they were actually very useful
for just whatever needed done.
I think that our Scouts have capabilities far beyond
their peers that they may not really appreciate.
just in being able to work together as a group sometimes
and having even the most basic first aid knowledge
or the idea of having your head clear
in an emergency, that would put them past their peers
and a lot of adults, I wouldn't hesitate to say.
Just being able to be comfortable and safe
in the outdoors overnight and over a weekend,
knowing about rain gear and staying warm,
staying cool, staying hydrated. they'll don't know that.
Tom and Larry, do you guys have any kind of?
have you done any kind of like emergency drills
or participate in any kind of community events like that
that Walter described,
The Air Force Base nearby their emergency drill?
they will call us to come and be the victims.
You know, we'll have a little name tag,
and that's about as extensive as it's gotten
In. Walter, one of Walter's posts mentions
that you just can't go volunteer anymore.
You have to go through some sort of training
and you've got to be on the list.
I don't know. aside from hurricanes,
we don't get earthquakes and we don't get
you know, we get some tornadoes occasionally
but they're not like the kind like
they get in the Midwest.
You know, the guys do a search and rescue
in the troop for emergency preparedness.
They'll have a little you know
emergency preparedness thing for their merit badge
or they'll do a camp, but we haven't done a lot of that.
There was a set of very severe storms
on the East Coast last week
That left a lot of people in Virginia and West Virginia
even now, a week later, without electricity.
I'm curious to know whether you know
whether Scouts will mobilize to help out with that.
So this is a program by the BSA
that encourages us to get involved
with local emergency preparedness agencies,
community agencies and one of the main ones being CERT,
And CERT is- help me out, Walter. you know what CERT is-
Community emergency response team-
and Scouts are in good shape to do CERT work.
The first aid portion of it is typically
kind of somewhere between a first aid merit badge, certainly,
and Wilder's first aid actually was originally
when help is delayed.
So Wilder's first aid is perfect for a disaster.
Scouts know a lot of things that go into that.
Some of the other things are: how is emergency response
organized, with incident command and the different divisions,
which is a good thing to know that a lot of Scouts
end up helping out in a very local way.
So they're the people who know how to wash dishes
with a camp stove and no dishwasher maybe.
So very simple stuff like that.
You know you could be a big help just with neighbors.
You- I'll have a link on the post
that contains this podcast on the blog there
to these different resources. as we mentioned them.
There's CERT and then there's also the BSA program.
You know we could take a look at various.
you might look at different agencies
and then we talked about Red Cross might be the sheriff
fire department. fire department is very good
at organizing incident command.
They do that all the time
And there may be just something like in our community
we get flash floods in the winter
And so there's sandbag locations
and you can fill sandbags and hand out sandbags
And so whatever, just kind of some opportunity
like that in your area
think about, when it comes to, you know,
relatively untrained, with enthusiasm.
You know that's your chance.
Program I was mentioning was emergency preparedness
for Boy Scouts and it's a program
of Boy Scouts of America.
It's been around for several years
and there is a pin that you can get, if you so desire,
for doing a few requirements.
And for Boy Scouts there are three requirements.
One is to earn first aid
and emergency preparedness merit badge.
One's to participate in creating an emergency plan
for your home
And one is participating in emergency preparedness training
conducted by community agency.
And I got to looking at that.
I'm going to send that over to the patrol leaders council
see if I can get them interested in that.
But the secret, Clark, is what you just said is
is I think I'm going to point my PLC.
See, that's you know, too often somebody calls
the scout master and the scout master says, oh sure
You know, and goes and organizes 20 or 30 scouts
And that's really. I mean
it's certainly an emergency. that can be done
because you know there's nothing wrong
with us helping out,
But most of the time it ought to be like you said,
you pointing the PLC. why don't you go call this guy?
You know we do the research to find things like that
that are compatible with our program.
We kind of check them out ahead of time, off to the side.
But but we don't do them
And we point the guys at them
And sometimes they'll disappoint us,
They'll just blow it off.
But other times, when they jump on the bandwagon
for stuff like that, it's really kind of neat.
They take off and that's when the really good stuff-
to me anyway- happens.
There is a great resource that is
Assert Youth Disaster Training Resources page.
It's a PDF file and I'll make sure to link to that
on the podcast,
But that has a lot of different ideas
about different agencies that you can partner with.
I looked up on the SERT website what I could find locally
And there's actually quite a few out there
And it looks as though they would be very interested
in partnering with scout troops
and helping to provide training and things like that.
That's where, if you've got the time to do the training,
that's what you're, that's what we're talking about.
but in a true emergency, what you said in the beginning,
where you just you call everybody
and take them there immediately, is totally different.
But yeah, I agree,
Let the scouts buy into it and go with that direction.
Yeah, I think the last thing I would want to see
if I was running a community disaster training course
would be somebody showing up with 15 or 20 boys
who had absolutely no interest in it at all
because somebody just thought it was a good idea.
Right, that's what you have: spontaneous volunteers
who are people who just show up and you know,
it's kind of like Little Rascals-
hey, kids, let's make a movie.
And then you've got typed resources,
and a typed resources says somebody
who can operate this radio, you know, with these forms
and that kind of stuff.
And so if you have a typed resource,
then you can just say you go do this
and the problem is solved. but you'll never have enough.
You know, we've reflected that we're kind of ahead
of the game just because we're used to going camping.
You know, everybody has this kind of mindfulness
about watching out for each other
and everybody has at least a basic level
of first aid training.
The scouts have proven again and again
over the past century that they're very valuable
in emergencies.
Most of these agencies, most of these response agencies,
want people to have a level of training,
And it's not necessarily a really sophisticated level
of training. it's just a little. you know
they want people not to create greater emergencies
by quote unquote helping out,
And so you'll need groups that are competent
but maybe not specific and you'll have holes to fill.
And I think that's really where the scouts are gonna fit in.
And you know we have the ePREP Merit Badge
which says: take place in a practice or a real emergency.
We can't schedule the real emergencies,
but those are, and maybe it's time for ePREP
to be updated with InstaCommand System.
I think that I'm really looking forward
to the search and rescue merit badge.
Yeah, that was just recently announced.
within the past couple of weeks,
new merit badge, SAR, search and rescue.
Have you looked at that any closer
than the announcement at all? Walter,
I have not seen any requirements.
I've seen that the right people are involved
in doing the merit badge and kind of defining it.
And actually the new radio merit badge
was updated a little fairly recently
And there's been a big uptick in radio merit badge
and involvement with the radio amateurs
and just communication. that's another thing to get trained in.
And are you a counselor for radio?
I have. I've taught the course a couple of times
And the guys like it. one of the things we do
is something like a scavenger hunt,
search and rescue kind of thing
where you've got somebody running net control
and a couple of teams out getting directions
And the updates to the merit badge
change things so that how did they change?
So there's a regular kind of updating,
but there's been a new memorandum of understanding
between the Scouts and AWRL about working on it.
There's several portable or not portable,
but loaner radio stations now available
from National that were donated by ICOM
So people can sign up for that
and get a multiple radio set up for a special event
for summer camp.
This sort of goes back to the emergency prep stuff.
for the first day there was a cub pack.
We use them as our patients
and they put them out on the playground
like this kid fell out of the swing
and there's a little chicken bone with some blood
sticking out of the shirt
And we'd have the patrols go out
and assess what had just happened to this kid
and perform the appropriate first day.
Yeah, scenarios are tremendous for teaching first aid
and moulage the fake wounds.
If you get actually get the guys into that,
that can be really, really fun.
I'm not sure that having the guys come up
with the scenarios is a good idea
because they tend to either make them insanely clever,
or that someone was like attacked by ninjas
and fell out of a helicopter or something
and you know it's not you kind of need.
it's an instructional thing.
It needs to have just the right level of challenge.
The whole setting it up,
especially with the fake wounds, and then you know
people, it's a great thing to get good at.
Yeah, I was thinking the other day
I guess some people are risk managers,
some people are risk averse
and then some people are just risk ignore,
which, along the way, might have been me occasionally
And for some reason,
we always had all the right stuff there,
but it occasionally almost seemed like an accident.
I think that it was an artifact
of actually doing the program
and having first aid and first aid merit badge
and safety- and you know, back in my day,
safety merit badge and stuff-
we just ended up with enough stuff
and we didn't even know about it-
adults or scouts to some extent-
because I don't think of myself
as a risk manager very much or very well,
And maybe I just do it in the back of my head-
and enough that we haven't had any disasters.
Well, you know, I like what you said about
you know, when things have happened on your trips,
that you already kind of knew what to do.
You had this stuff and you had,
because really being prepared
is not about hauling huge amounts of stuff,
It's about what's in your head
and what's kind of in your fingers, that you've practiced it,
that you teach first aid every year
and you learn that, relearn it every year that way.
So, and that's what the emergency drills are about
and that's you know those kind of things
is that's why we talk on the radio every week
with the volunteers,
just so that when something happens you know what to do.
I've been on the scene of a couple of road accidents.
I've been there when people were trying to revive somebody
with CPR and you know, instead of being one of the 20
or 30 people who are standing there watching
you, basically you know what to do.
And a lot of that goes back to the way that we work
in scouts, and I like what you said, Larry.
you said it's an artifact of doing the program.
What seems to be, I mean, it seems to come out of it most.
most of the time we do okay, you know,
and not that Larry is such a great
and wonderful risk manager
and took all of this into account ahead of time.
You know, I can't really say that.
I think it gets. it's part of the culture of scouting-
Let's say it that way- that we do inherently risky activities
and we have to be prepared to understand what those risks are
and be able to respond to things that go wrong.
And you know, if you've been around for a few years
and you've gone through these things several different times,
they're kind of second nature,
An artifact of the program.
I'm fascinated with the phrase.
I think that's a very good way of saying it.
On May 30th I had an event.
The fire truck showed up in about two minutes
and then the ambulance was there-
I don't know, I guess- a minute later
and those guys were just amazing
And of course it was in the hospital
where all the real work took place
and they put a stand in my heart and the whole thing.
I mean those guys. it was amazing how,
but they just knew exactly what to do.
My doctor said they saved my life.
I guess I've had several scouts
who have ended up as firemen and EMTs along the way
and I think scouting does prepare not only the skills,
but the mindset and I guess, if you wanna use
that artifact of the program kind of idea,
but I mean if you can be as prepared
as these guys are, and of course
they have all the equipment and all the stuff,
but still they've trained, they knew what to do,
They didn't just kind of stand there and go,
they went right to work
And I'm impressed,
Yeah, they practice, practice, practice.
If they haven't done it in a week they'll practice.
Well, and I had something about: oh, four years ago
we had a meeting of our company emergency response team
and we did CPR, kind of just a refresher,
and Heimlich and stuff. and that evening at dinner
my older son choked on a piece of shrimp
as in not breathing, choked.
And so my other son, Scout, calls 911
and I did the Heimlich and got it out.
and you really have to honk on somebody
to get that to work, I'll tell you that.
But by the time they got there he was breathing again.
That's what practice is for.
There's a troop down the road 12 miles
and the Scout master is on the eccentric side
and he- they were doing a model rocket shoot. one day
He built his own engine.
The alarms, the alarms are going off right now.
You better believe it.
He touched the match to it and it blew up
and a piece of shrapnel went through
and cut his femoral artery.
The Scouts- immediately all the Scouts around-
saw that and they jumped on him,
jumped on that thing and put pressure on it
and they called 911, the ambulance finally got there.
They told him that if the Scouts hadn't been there-
you know, if they somebody else had been there
that didn't know what to do,
he'd have bled to death in just a few minutes.
but the Scouts knew exactly what to do
and how to do it and it happened just instantly
and they saved his life.
Wow,
So, yeah, so we call him Rocket Man now.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha ha.
But yeah, that was a scary time for him and you know
You hear stories like that kind of regularly
If you look for them. they're happening all the time.
Somebody administers the Heimlich maneuver,
somebody uses CPR, somebody uses
that very basic first aid knowledge that they have,
and you know they absolutely can save people's lives
or prevent them from, you know, a greater injury.
That is one of the things
that is extraordinarily common
from my experience in Scouting Circles.
The BSA has the National Court of Honor
that will present heroism awards to Scouts.
They always had a feature in Boy's Life
about a heroism award that had been issued
Scouts in action.
I always turn to Scouts in action first.
It's interesting. I feel like those are probably
under awarded in a lot of councils.
I don't think people are quite aware of those
because, yeah, there's three levels or something on that.
The highest level is an honor medal with crossed palms
and that is a scout that's demonstrated unusual heroism
or extraordinary skill or resourcefulness
in saving or attempting to save a life
at extreme risk to themselves.
And then there are several different levels of honor medal.
There's a national certificate of merit
and that is for someone who has performed
a significant act of service
that is deserving of national recognition.
And then I think what you were referring to, Walter,
is something called the local council certificate of merit,
And this situation does not meet the criteria
for the National Court of Honor Award
but is an act deserving of recognition.
I had several years ago, two boys
within the course of a year or two
who administered the Heimlich maneuver
to a family member, one to a younger brother
and one to a grandfather.
I was made aware of that and I did file
for a local council certificate of merit
because I thought it met that criteria
and we were able to present those to them.
So, Walter, I think you're right.
I think these things are kind of under rewarded
because I don't know that everyone is aware
that they're available.
Well, and I think the Medal of Merit
is one that's. some acts of meritorious service above and beyond
may involve life-saving. it's not confined to life-saving
And so- but you know, Heimlich maneuver
or something like that,
it's can be awarded for any meritorious action
using some aspect of scouting skills or learning.
Well, there you go.
So you know that's.
I think we should recognize scouts and scouts
for doing this kind of thing.
I think it's an important aspect
of helping everybody understand, you know,
what a contribution it makes to the community
when you're actually prepared for something,
And you may be more prepared than you realize.
Hope so,
Hope so.
Well, you always feel a lot less prepared
than you would like to be,
but you may be the best prepared person in the room
for the first hundred or so scouts that cut their fingers.
You just, you know, begin to get good at it.
I'm up to 287. right now
There could be award, for
you could have like an extra little scout
you know device on that, one for each one,
An Oakleaf cluster
With Band-Aid,
With Band-Aid for a minimum of two stitches.
I think we covered what I was looking to cover
Next time. I don't know if you want to talk
about Courts of Honor or ideas, or
Oh, that'd be a great idea.
Well, I had another idea,
which was adults staying in shape.
How do you keep up with scouts?
Yeah, I'd like to hear that one too.
Thanks very much, fellas,
for joining us again for the panel on this podcast.
Walter, thanks very much.
Well, thank you,
And that one resource for youth
in the disaster stuff was fantastic.
I'm gonna be going through that.
Yeah, I'm gonna be looking at that too.
Tom, I hope it gets cooler for you down there.
We do too. thanks a lot,
And Larry, thanks very much for joining us. Larry,
You're welcome. Clark,
It's been fun.
Well, thank you so much for listening
to this edition of the Scout Master Podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch.
I hope you enjoyed it.
I'll see you in the next one.
Bye.
You can read the Scout Master blog at scoutmastercgcom.
You can subscribe there to receive updates
to the blog by email.
You can subscribe to the Scout Master podcast on iTunes
And when you do, please leave a comment
or review a rating.
We so appreciate it.
You can also access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio.
Get details about how to do that at stitchercom.
You can send a shout out to the podcast
by going to scoutmastercgcom backslash shout out.
You can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
That's right.
You can follow us at Scout Master blog on Facebook.
You can tweet Scout Master CG on Twitter
And, for admittance to the exclusive
Scout Master CG circles,
search for Scout Master CG on Google Plus.
And if none of that appeals to you,
well, we can use good old fashioned email.
That's right.
You can email me, Clark Green,
your comments, questions and wild ideas
at scoutmastercg at Verizonnet.
The Scout Master blog and the Scout Master podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
Hey, it's just me.
I have a microphone and I'm trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders and maybe have a little bit
of fun along the way.
Before we leave you, let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Bidden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.